dinamita y gases lacrimógenos en las
calles de la paz los cocaleros de la
asociación departamental de productores
de coca adepcoca empezaron a protestar
el primero de agosto acusan al gobierno
de luis arce de respaldar al grupo de
cultivadores a que consideran ilegal y
piden que se respete la ley 906 que les
otorgó licencias para la producción y
venta de la planta lo que nosotros
queremos no cierres el mercado ilegal
eso es lo que pedimos como yungas de la
paz como los yungueños
nosotros quiero que respeten nuestra ley
nuestro mercado
adecco que administra el principal
mercado de coca en la capital boliviana
y afirma que el gobierno protege al
grupo que lo administra por razones
políticas
no hay justicia no un valor se va al
vice ministerio a querer hacer el
diálogo donde nos quieren enfriar pero
no lo van a lograr porque estamos en
lucha llevándolo hasta detrás de estas
divisiones de confrontamiento porque
eres un dirigente político fracasado lo
que quieres nuevamente postularse a la
presidencia y quiere nuevamente
recuperar la gente dividiendo
confrontando por supuesto avalando a la
coca ilegal que hace con xicola 906 en
bolivia la coca es clasificada como una
planta sagrada debido a los usos
tradicionales de los andinos como la
masticación y la medicina ancestral que
se practican ampliamente en el país pero
la hoja de coca es la principal materia
prima de cocaína y bolivia es el tercer
productor mundial de este narcótico
después de colombia y perú